foreign
on this Sunday night a matter of life
and death
shortage of paramedics across Canada a
lot of them are long-term vacancies that
they just haven't been able to fill
what's required to recruit desperately
needed help
from drought to drenched
flash floods in parts of the U.S and
fears of fatalities
Brits in for a shock how much their
energy prices are soaring and what's
fueling it
and a heart melting store ready to go
best job I've ever had the scoop on how
he became one City's ice cream man
[Music]
global national with barnasser reporting
tonight nitu gunshot good evening and
thanks for joining us paramedics across
Canada are struggling to answer and
respond to emergency calls mostly
because of Staffing shortages some
emergency rooms are even being forced to
close for hours or for days four
premiers are set to discuss the
country's Health Care crisis tomorrow
and as Catherine urquhart reports it's
already what some people call a crisis
that's affecting too many Canadians
[Applause]
it's a crisis across the country a
shortage of paramedics is causing delays
everywhere in major cities and in
smaller towns Jackie Joyce broke her hip
and waited more than 10 hours for an
ambulance they knew it wasn't acceptable
for me to have had to wait that long
with that kind of an injury the
ambulance paramedics Union of BC says
recruitment strategies aren't working
noting there are nearly 1 000 vacancies
in Metro Vancouver which has a
population of approximately 2.5 million
people the shortage is impacting all
communities and there's little
flexibility for shifting staff to
accommodate changing demands the
challenges you have is that when you're
short staffed in many areas or short of
ambulances you can't move them around
with that ability because you're
depleted already in many areas so that's
why we're facing these challenges right
now in Manitoba the province is trying
to free up paramedics by creating a
dedicated service to transport low
Acuity patients to medical appointments
our government is helping Ontario's
Health System recover and rebuild
we're making the largest Health
infrastructure investment in the
province's history Ontario Premier Doug
Ford claims he's working on improving
the overall health care system by
expanding a program that allows
paramedics to avoid taking patients to
the ER on every call
ottawa's Mayor calls the status quo a
public safety risk and is calling on the
province to fund 42 new paramedic jobs
in the city but finding recruits is
difficult across Canada we need to be
able to meet competitive with uh other
professions like police fire health care
because we're really lagging behind in
that and that's really hurting our
ability to recruit for now the Staffing
shortages and ambulance delays are
likely to continue Catherine urquhart
Global News Vancouver
in BC a tragic incident last night has
left two people dead and 10 others
hospitalized after a vehicle crashed
into a wedding party
police say a woman next door was pulling
her car out of a driveway she somehow
accelerated forward instead driving into
wedding guests two people are now in
critical condition the driver was also
taken to hospital but not arrested she
is cooperating with police
the latest in a string of supply
shortages leaving store shelves bare
across Canada involves pain medication
for children parents have been having a
tough time finding liquid Tylenol and
Advil Kylie Stanton explains what's
causing the problem and the warning not
to Panic by
the stock here has been dwindling for
months now no Children's Tylenol or
Advil meaning no relief for sick kids or
their parents they're in very short
supply shelves are empty shelves are
bare it's just the latest in a series of
shortages of over-the-counter
medications Nationwide what health
Canada confirms stems from challenges
sourcing raw ingredients significantly
higher than normal demand as well as
supply chain issues it's almost
impossible I found it at Costco and you
could see like it was being like picked
through so quickly in a statement it
says it urges patients not to buy more
medication than usual this will help
ensure that all Canadians continue to
have access to the medications they need
and it will also help prevent drug
shortages if somebody is hoarding it or
taking more than they need then that
means it's not available for somebody
else who might need it under a different
circumstance there's always going to be
options that we can give parents for
children the shortage is specific to
liquid formulas generic brands are
equally effective there are also
chewable tablets as well as
suppositories and some children may be
able to take a portion of adult
medication but doctors warn parents
should not try to adjust doses at home
these medications are weight based
they're not age-based so you can talk to
your pharmacist or your doctor give the
weight of your child and together you
can compute the dose that the child is
allowed to have the good news is unlike
other parts of the country there is
currently no issue with Supply in the
provincial Health Care system and while
Ontario is looking at requiring a
prescription for the children who need
access to the medication VC's Health
Minister says that's not necessary here
just yet but is also not ruling anything
out it's not inconceivable but it's
something that we Monitor and in this
case we monetary on a daily basis to
make sure we're taking the measures we
need to take while there is no telling
when the Supply will return to normal
try and keep Pace with cold and flu
season Kylie Stanton Global News
in Russia a suspected Car Bomb has
killed the daughter of an ultra
nationalist who's linked to Vladimir
Putin Daria dugina was the child of
Alexander Dugan a prominent ideologue
who's been called Putin's brain and
believed to have influenced him on the
invasion of Ukraine she was initially
traveling with his father who then
switched vehicles at some point an
explosive device beneath the car she was
driving later detonated killing her a
state news agency reports it's believed
Alexander was the intended target
foreign
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
is worried that attack coupled with this
week's Independence Day Celebrations
could lead to more Russian aggression in
his nightly address Saturday he says
Russia may try to do something
particularly nasty and cruel as Ukraine
marks 31 years of Independence and six
months since moscow's Invasion began
another drone strike has hit Russian
forces stationed in Crimea the latest in
a string of attacks on the Russian
annexed region
more than eight months after he took
office Germany's chancellor is beginning
his first official visit to Canada
tonight Olaf Schultz is starting his
three-day tour in Montreal as Kyle
Benning explains the main focus of
Scholl's trip is to grow Germany's
energy profile by buying Canadian
hydrogen
Trudeau and Olaf Schultz will renew
pleasantries this week when the Prime
Minister hosts the German Chancellor the
visit includes meetings about a number
of issues from the war in Ukraine to
climate change
on the final day of the trip the leaders
are a Newfoundland they are it is
expected they will sign a deal making
Germany a key customer of Canada's
hydrogen energy sector while the first
shipments from a proposed facility is
still years away it marks a shift
towards green energy on top of helping
an ally there are sources of of
developing hydrogen of producing
hydrogen in Canada that we know are
going to be more and more important
in the coming years Canada's former
ambassador to Germany says while
specific details around this deal and
others have yet to be hammered out it's
a positive step but a lot of discussion
about intention and and working together
so this this is very much a planning
visit critics say this does little for
Germany's immediate dependence on Russia
worse Europe is contending with surging
natural gas prices gas prom Russia's
state-owned energy producer says the
Nordstrom pipeline will be shut down for
three days at the end of August for
maintenance this follows the federal
government's decision to return a
turbine for that pipeline to Europe
bypassing Russian sanctions earlier this
month Germany's foreign affairs minister
called out President Vladimir Putin for
withholding Russian energy as a
political maneuver he tried to play
games with us and now the whole world
can see crystal clear that he is just
using energy as a gameplay nordstream is
running at 20 percent of its capacity
and gas prom's maintenance announcement
has raised more questions Ukraine's
ambassador to Canada is calling on
Ottawa to reconsider its stance on
bypassing the sanctions need to Kyle
Benning in Toronto thanks Kyle
after 30 excruciating hours the hostage
Siege at a popular hotel in somalia's
capital is over much of the building is
destroyed somalia's Elite Armed Forces
ended the ordeal overnight killing the
gunman on Friday the group stormed the
hotel opening fire and setting off bombs
tonight at least 21 people are dead
about 100 more are injured and 15 are in
critical condition the militant group
al-shabab is taking responsibility for
the attack
days of intense Monsoon rain have killed
at least 50 people throughout India many
residents have now been displaced from
their homes as heavy rains and flood
waters sweep through hundreds of
villages in the northern state of
uttarakhand more than a dozen people
have vanished in worsening conditions
and in the Himalayan state of Himachal
Pradesh officials there say landslides
and floods have killed at least 36
people over the past three days
water is also wreaking havoc south of
our border tonight downpours have now
soaked states that were in dire need of
rain this summer triggering flash floods
and millions of Americans are bracing
themselves for more flooding Jennifer
Johnson looks at the damage that's been
caused and the danger
after months of scorching heat no
precipitation and wildfires burning up
the U.S Southwest now this
heavy rain and flash flooding are
hitting parts of Arizona New Mexico
Texas and Utah in Zion National Park
there's a desperate search for a hiker
who disappeared near a rising River we
did receive a report from folks who had
not been in the narrows at the time of
the flash flood who said that someone
from their party was missing friends and
family members are holding out hope the
woman is clinging to a branch or debris
Downstream and will be found alive I'm
very hopeful that she can make she's a
good fighter in Arizona Friday another
alarming rescue about 30 children were
lifted to safety after their school bus
ran into fast rising water and started
to Teeter
they're gonna put them on the back of
the truck search and rescue officials in
the Tucson area are warning hikers to
take precautions after a harrowing
operation earlier this month a fire
truck letter had to be lowered over a
River Canyon to bring 21 adults and four
children to safety the region is still
under a flood advisory you could be
easily Swept Away there's also a lot of
debris that can get washed through the
canyon and the water is pretty dark so
you may not see that the rain was
welcomed in many areas where
record-breaking temperatures and severe
drought conditions have scorched the
Earth that saturation right now is going
to help us tremendously so you know
although none of us want to be stuck in
a flood none of us want to be stuck in
the driving rain we are grateful that
we're getting that now but in some areas
it was too much rain too fast the dry
Earth couldn't absorb all the
precipitation and Roads turned into
rivers oh boy stormy weather is now
moving into the U.S Northeast which is
also withered under excessive Heat this
summer forecasters are predicting
drought relief but but also an increased
risk of dangerous flooding
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
coming up the high profile Witnesses set
to testify at the Nova Scotia Massacre
inquiry
[Music]
two high-profile mounties are set to
testify over the rcmp's response to the
2020 Nova Scotia Massacre what they have
to say could be critical especially as
political controversy looms over it
here's Callum Smith
after a House of Commons committee
Tuesday heard repeated allegations of
political interference involving the
Force's top boss during the Nova Scotia
mass shooting investigation RCMP
commissioner Brenda Luckey is set to
testify at the mass casualty
commissioned this coming week it was
clear during that meeting that the
commissioner had said that she had made
a promise and that it was tied to the
legislation luck you will be testifying
about the April 2020 killings in
Colchester County when 22 innocent
people lost their lives she's been under
Fire about a teleconference 10 days
after the Rampage began with multiple
Nova Scotia senior ranking officers
describing a tense and upsetting call
with the commissioner lucky issued a
statement two years later about two
months ago saying she regretted how she
approached that call Chief
superintendents Darren Campbell and
Chris leather have both testified at the
inquiry about their feelings that there
was interference in the investigation
alleging pressure from Ottawa to release
details of the weapons used both Lucky
and then Public Safety Minister Bill
Blair have denied the interference
allegations also due to testify will be
Nova Scotia assistant commissioner Lee
bergerman the House of Commons committee
heard from her in July so you heard the
commissioner say she promised the
minister and the prime minister's office
yes did the commissioner like you
directly tie that to the forthcoming
firearm policy from the liberal
government yes bergerman was the
division's commanding officer at the
time in the massacre she retired in
October the inquiry has set aside three
days in all to hear from the two
witnesses the inquiry has been on a
three-week Hiatus from public
proceedings Global News asked what work
has been ongoing behind the scenes a
staffer tells us the commission is
getting ready for the upcoming testimony
and phase three of its work that
includes more public proceedings and
possibly roundtables as well as quote
creating opportunities for input from
those most affected as well as the
general public and the Commissioners who
will be responsible for coming up with
recommendations as of now the inquiry
has public proceedings scheduled until
September 22nd before its final report
with findings lessons and
recommendations due November 1st Callum
Smith Global News Halifax
escalating Energy prices in the UK ahead
the struggle and the potential Solutions
many Canadians have been struggling with
soaring inflation and the problem isn't
isolated to this country it is worldwide
in Europe the biggest challenge is the
rising cost of energy all because of
Russia's war on Ukraine Redmond Shannon
explains the Staggering new level the
UK's electricity bills could soar to and
what the government plans to do about it
with UK inflation now above 10 percent
many food banks are reporting Rising
demand and falling donations and things
could be about to get a whole lot worse
here I was talking to one woman and she
said that she's having to give her house
off and everything because she can't
afford to run it post covet energy
demand and the war in Ukraine means the
price of turning on the lights and the
heat is way up and it's set to Skyrocket
we see Putin deliberately use energy as
a tool to get back at us for the help
we're putting into Ukraine and that is
obviously impacting families because of
energy costs five out of every six homes
in Britain use natural gas for heating
and 40 percent of the electricity is
generated using gas although almost none
of that comes from Russia the spiking
Global Market for gas is still driving
up UK utility bills from 2 thousand
dollars a year for the average home to
as high as nearly 8 000 by next spring
some European governments like France
and Italy are capping such increases the
UK is instead offering rebates but
analysts say those measures are nowhere
near enough to help the poorest if those
Bill increases go through for this
coming winter more than half of the
entire country will be classed as being
in energy fuel poverty that's how
extreme the Rises are in the UK fuel
poverty is where more than 10 percent of
household income goes to energy
meanwhile the two candidates to replace
outgoing prime minister Boris Johnson
are debating how best to tackle the
issue you know Liz's plan is to say well
I I believe in tax cuts not direct
support I don't think that's right
critics say time is running out to
prevent a catastrophe for the poor when
you know there is a crisis of
magnificent proportions coming you do
not say well we'll just have to wait
until we got a change in our leadership
you start dealing with it now photos of
the departing Johnson on his second
foreign vacation of the summer only
further in Rage opponents his office
says no new energy measures will be
taken until his successor is elected
next month Redmond Shannon Global News
London
Woody scooter ice cream man who's making
kids smile in BC
a lot of people will have a lot of
different jobs in their lives and at 64
years old one BC man isn't retiring but
he is chilling out as Jay Durant shows
you Daryl Ralph has reinvented himself
as an ice cream guy and is serving up
Joy to his City
it's going to be another busy day after
a quick setup Daryl Ralph's Ice Cream
stand is open for business everything's
ready to go
best job I've ever had won banana ice
Daryl built up his icicle tricycle
ordering parts from all over and then
hitched it to his Mobility Scooter I
want to get out and make people smile
every day make people forget about uh
what's going on and enjoy themselves he
got all the pieces to fit the part
whether it's the music or the outfit
they just gravitate towards him
Daryl lost his leg to cancer in the
1980s I only have to buy one shoe I get
discount he's having some trouble right
now he'll have surgery in the fall to
deal with an infection this helps keep
his mind off it and green this is
what it was all about it's not to sit
home and whine about me it's to get out
and make everyone else happy thank you
you're welcome the little boy came up
and he walks up and he hugs my leg and
he says I want to thank you for the ice
cream yesterday it was so good
he's become a bit of a celebrity in
Chilliwack coming down here the horns
are going people waving it's just
fantastic I get it everywhere I was
driving and I saw him and screamed I'm
like we have to find the ice cream man
like I didn't even like really feel like
ice cream but it was just like I just
wanted the experience oh that's cool he
might add a hot dog stand next summer if
the surgery goes well and he can start
wearing his prosthetic again annoying
Daryl he will he'll be back caramel
drumstick for now he's found a pretty
sweet summer job his first season as
chilliwax ice cream man it's an ice
cream kind of day I can't believe it
it's been extraordinary yeah the town
and people that I've met and people from
all over the world it's been fantastic
very overwhelming around bread and joy
yes there you go
I've got the best office in all of
Canada if I don't like it I just moved
down the trail
Jay Durant Global News
and one more congrats tonight to the
exhausted BC man who just shattered a
world record
[Applause]
is so from Burnaby performed
7087 chin-ups in 24 hours finishing this
morning the old record was 5400.
coincidentally a man from New York State
attempted the same thing this weekend
but stopped after hearing about his
Canadian counterpart well done Marcus
that is global national for this Sunday
night I'm nitu garcha thanks for
watching Farah Nasser will be at the
anchor desk tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Music]